à tout seigneur tout honneur d'abord la
reine d'Angleterre en France tailleur
saumon sur tapis rouge c'est un accueil
en grande pompe qui a été réservé à la
reine elliizabeth II pour son 3e voyage
officiel en France dès son arrivée à
Orly la souveraine britannique a
réaffirmé avec force et en français
l'attachement de son pays à l'Europe
trème visite d'État je vous le disais la
première en 57 sous René cotti la 2e en
1072 Philipp parwir était déjà à la
RTF
difficile en 1972 de distinguer la
couleur des atours de la reine reçue par
Georges Pompidou 20 ans plus tard pas de
problème c'est l'abcot qui domine la
petite histoire remarquera qu'Élisabeth
II vient à Paris le jour de la saint
Diane Diana en anglais pur
hasard la grande Histoire retiendra que
les premières paroles royales sont un
crédau Européen qui ne peut que séduire
son hôte François
mitéran la Grande-Bretagne a sa place au
cœur de l'Europe et l'avenir de l'Europe
se confond avec le
sien c'est seulement en étant
étroitement lié à la France qu'elle
pourra tirer le meilleur parti des
ouvertures et des chances que lui offre
l'Europe Paris c'est une lumière qui
sintille dans les imaginations disait
déjà ellisabeth il y a 20 ans
aujourd'hui la Ville Lumière a tenu ses
[Musique]
promesses pour recevoir et acclamer le
couple royal qui se rend à pied de sa
résidence de l'hôtel de Marini au Palais
de
l'Élysée cet après-midi changement de
tenue jaune Canarie oblige pour une
promenade en bateau sur le bassin de la
Villette en route vers la cité des
sciences tiens tiens Jacques Lang en
profite pour réviser son
anglais en tout cas visite studieuse de
la France contemporaine et inventive
finalement Elizabeth II ne se sent pas
dépaysée ici elle a même retrouver le
rarissime cabriolet utilisé il y a 20
ans et on dira que les Français ne sont
pas
conservateurs plusieurs milliers de
Parisiens et de touristes sétaient massé
sur les champsélysée vers midi pour
acclamer la souveraine même le soleil
était de la fête et parmi les Badeau
extasiés Bernard
lebrin
dernière répétition pour le salut à la
reine qui a eu la géniale idée de
remonter la plus belle avenue du monde à
l'heure du déjeuner j'étais en train de
dire il y a pas la garde à cheval pour
la re c'est drôle parce que d'habitude
c'est quand même le grand apparat mais
si mais si Madame l'apparat sera à la
hauteur de l'événement soyez rassurés
pas facile il est vrai de voir quelque
chose entre deux panneaux publicitaires
les marchands de périsc en carton ont
disparu avec les foules d'entan mais
garde est là avec un peu de chance
chacun pourra apercevoir sa Majesté en
compagnie du président de la République
attention regardez bien petit signe de
la main inexorablement la décapotable
avance c'est
fini madame vous avez pu voir la reine
oui oui elle elle avait un chapeau oui
avait un chapeau orange j'ai la belle
voiture CELI la le chapeau plus que cel
de larê C Jol et puis il y a ceux qui
sont bloqués et s'offrent une pause
contraints et forcés vous avez vu
quelque chose comment vous avez vu
passer quelque chose euh oui oui oui
mais vous attendez quoi là bah passer de
l'autre
côté avant il faut que les chevaux
regagnent l'écurie poursuivie image
étonnante par ces drôles de machines
vertees les balayeuses ramasseuse de
crotte nettoyé les Champs-Élysées sont
réouverts la reine est passée les
livreurs traversent la vie
continue avec la reine d'Angleterre une
autre Élisabeth et l'héroïne du jour
ellisabeth Guigou ministre des affaires
européennes qui va tenir ce soir à
celesta un sur les enjeux de mastrich un
meeting commun avec Valérie giscardestin
au total une dizaine de meetings
rassemblant des ministres des
responsables socialistes et des
dirigeants de l'UDF sont prévus d'ici la
fin de ce mois cette initiative du
mouvement européen a provoqué hier soir
la colère de l'état-major du RPR qui a
publié dans la soirée un communiqué
mettant en demeure Valérie cardestin et
les dirigeants de l'UDF de renoncer à
ces réunions publiques sous peine de
conséquences graves pour l'union de
l'opposition l'ancien président de la
République a décidé de maintenir sa
venue pour le meeting de céesta il s'en
est expliqué il y a quelques minutes
auprès de nos confères de FR3 qui lui
ont rappeler que le RPR l'accusé en
quelque sorte de donner un coup de main
au président de la
République il s'agit pas de Françis
mitteran il s'agit du traité de
Maastricht alors faut tout de même pas
abaisser dégrader le le débat politique
en France vous savez que les Français
sont très lassés du comportement de leur
classe politique et ils souhaitent que
les hommes politiques leur parlent des
problèmes qui se posent alors il y a 3
mois on la campagne des régionale moi je
suis resté en Auvergne et j'ai parlé aux
auvergnas de de l'avenir de notre région
la région d'Auvergne on a voté gagner là
nous avons un traité qui est important
pour la France pour la France pas pour
les partis politiques pour les Français
leur vie quotidienne leur avenir les
jeunes et les Français ne savent pas
quel est le contenu de ce traité nous
allons leur expliquer de contradictoire
alors et puis ensuite à l'automne il y
aura un référendum et pour ce référendum
l'UDF fera sa propre campagne sous ses
propres couleurs avec ses propres
valeurs je propose de rejoindre tout de
suite celesta cette petite ville du
barrain qui va peut-être laisser son n
dans l'histoire contemporaine comment
vivent les militants dans l'attente de
ce meeting tout à fait inédit reportage
Olivier Lerner et Bruno Girodon je suis
pour
GIR mais pas pour GIR la route qui
conduit à Maastricht est décidément bien
compliquée pour l'opposition pour la
première fois en France les pro
Maastricht de gauche comme de droite se
retrouve face à face ou plutôt côte à
côte une première qui fait du bruit à
Paris mais qui vu d'Alsace n'aime pas
outre mesure les Européens du PS et de
l'UDF dans de mois ils vont se taper
dessus pour les législatives aujourd'hui
ils sont ensemble sur sur le même B je
trouve que c'est pas très logique je
trouve qu'onit tous se mettre d'accord
pour que ça avance correctement et sans
sans qu' débat intérieur c'est pas un
peu choquant un peu surréaliste de voir
une personnalité de gauche et de droite
sur une même estrade TR
intelligentuemon
éliminerie éc applaudir Mame guou
ministre des affaires européennes ça je
ne sais pas je suis toujours libre de
mes idées je ne sais pas ce qu'elle dit
ou n'importe quoi je peux pas applaudir
d'avance il faut d'abord que j'écoute
ils sont ven s'instruire avant tout le
traité de mastrich est en vente dans
cette salle 66 francs et il se vend
comme des petits pains
pendant ce temps-là à Paris les
sénateurs reprenaient l'examen de la
révision constitutionnelle préalable
vous savez à la ratification du traité
d'Union européenne après le vote négatif
des Danois au référendum un certain
nombre de sénateurs dont Charles pascoy
estim qu'il n'y a plus lieu à débattre
les socialistes et les centristes sont
l'avis contraire sur place reportage
Véronique Saint-Olive le Sénat à la
fièvre de mastrich et la majorité UDF
RPR manifeste en plus un symptôme aigu
de désunion les premiers veulent aller
de l'avant les autres non arrêter un
débat avant qu'il le commence et
toujours sur le plan parlementaire une
erreur qu'il est déraisonnable
d'ailleurs
contraire au droit international de
reprendre ce débat verrons bien tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous avez une
majorité qui pense la même chose que
vous nous verrons bien ça c'est son les
événement qui le prouveront qui le
démontreront mais de son côté Roland
Duma propose une seule potion il faut
avaler le traité de maastriicht tel quel
et sans grimace alors les communistes
s'emballent le RPR réclame à grand cri
une suspension de
séance
présentz consul les centristes et les
indépendants veulent eux aussi se
compter c'est la dispersion les
sénateurs se retrouveront après le dîner
pour une discussion générale ou pour une
bataille de procédure la nuit de toute
façon sera longue au Palais du
Luxembourg l'organisation de ces 10
meetings communs psudf pour défendre le
traité d'union politique européen signé
à mastriicht sucite de sérieux remou
dans les état-majors politiques nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure avec nos
invités Alain Jupé sur ce plateau ici
monveille qui est à Strasbourg au RPR
Jacques chabandelmas a décidé d'annuler
sa participation au meeting de Bordeaux
qui était prévu avec Roland Dumas et
Jean-François poncé par loyauté a-t-il
dit à l'égard du RPR grogne également au
PS où jeanpaupren qualifie cette
campagne commune de tout à fait
surprenante jeanppren qui réclame une
convocation d'urgence du comité
directeur du PS affirme que ce que la
France retiendra c'est je cite le
spectacle des chefs de la droite et du
PS sur les même trateau cette addition
de chef fera une soustraction de voix
tout de suite je vous propose de
retrouver Gill Leclerc qui est à
l'Assemblée nationale pour Antenne
2 bataille rangée ou Guera toujours
est-il que le communiqué du RPR a
provoqué un étrange duel au sein de
l'opposition sans qu'on sache vraiment
qui a dégainé le premier alors crise ou
pas au sens chinois il y a crise
c'est-à-dire c'est-à-dire qu'on est en
train de préparer une opportunité vision
optimiste de ceux qui ne veulent pas
dramatiser en attendance et bien chacun
de son côté que l'on s'est réuni cet
après-midi sans vraiment évoluer et les
échanges sont restés rares j'ava un
objectif tenu depuis 2 mois c'est à
entraîner le maximum des responsables de
l'opposition sur la ratification et
c'est mon seul objectif nous sommes
toujours prê à en discuter c'est très
bien tous nos collègues députés ont dit
une chose simple dans une démocratie où
on est dans la
on est dans l'opposition on peut pas
avoir un pied dans chaque camp un
ultimatum ce n'est jamais bon cela dit
j'espère qu'il est encore possible de
travailler pour entraîner le maximum de
responsables du RPR à voter la
ratification de Mr si les ponts ne sont
pas coupés chacun fait déjà ses comptes
et mesure l'étendue des dégâts sous
l'œil gognard de quelques autres il faut
jamais se réjouir du malheur des autres
simplement ce que je considère c'est que
observe comme tous les Français que la
droite est incapable de s'unir pour
quelque chose ce soir personne n'ose
encore prononcer le mot recomposition
mais chacun ne manque pas d'y songer et
d'être sur ses
gardes dernière réaction à noter celle
du Front national qui demande aux
dirigeants du RPR de tenir des meetings
communs avec les amis de Jean-Marie Le
Pen pour défendre l'Europe des patries
et le nom au
référendum maintenant le problème du RPR
c'est enfin d'avoir une position sur
l'Europe alors ou bien ils sont pour
Maastricht et après tout ils font des
meetings avec le Parti socialiste ou
bien ils sont contre Maastricht et
pourquoi pas tenir meeting avec le Front
National qui lui de tout temps a été
contre mastrich moi pour ma part je suis
prêt à tenir un meeting avec Monsieur
segin ou monsieur pasquy qui ont tenu
sur cette question là des propos qu'ils
ont largement repris les propositions de
Jean-Marie Le Pen du Front national à 9
mois des législative de mars prochain
alors que Jacques Chirac et Valérie
cardestin avaient réaffirmé sur tous les
tons leur volonté dans rait
définitivement la hâche de guerre alors
que l'opposition s'était mise d'accord
sur un processus de désignation d'un
candidat unique à la présidentielle UDF
et RPR sont donc au bord du divorce sur
cette question capitale pour l'avenir la
construction européenne récit d'un
désamour avec Roland SICAR et François
Braban avec la participation tout à fait
involontaire de Roulio Iglesias j'ai
besoin de
toi et oui c'est ça jiscar shirac 20 ans
de cohabitation quelques haut et
beaucoup de bas tenez après les
régionales ils étaient à tu et à toi
même les vieilles scènes de ménag sur
les primaires était oublié c'était union
union
[Musique]
union et puis Patat mastrich est passé
par là Chirac écoute moins giscar et
plus pasqu ou sin il veut un référendum
gisc n'en veut pas notre mouvement
souhaite et je dirais exige qu'une telle
réforme soit adoptée par la voix du
référendum pourquoi un référendum
franchement
mais et la belle histoire tourne au
vinaigre pourtant ils avaient l'occasion
de se rabibocher puisque le référendum
aura lieu de toute façon mais voilà
mastrich toujours mastrich giscar veut
maintenant faire des meetings en commun
avec les membres du PS Chirak crie à
l'infidélité allez nous on le connait le
fin mot de l'histoire ce qui le
craignent c'est de savoir comment tout
cela va finir parce que c'est bien
[Musique]
connu la
chance ce soir Albert Duroi c'est
peut-être le président du Parti radical
Yve galant qui résume le mieux la
situation il a affirmé sur Antenne 2
l'opposition est en train de gagner le
championnat du monde de masochisme
politique oui effectivement on savait
depuis longtemps que la droite comme la
gauche d'ailleurs mais elle dans une
moindre mesure que la droite était
divisée sur le traité d'un européenne
mais on savait aussi que ses principaux
leaders giscar Chirac Baladur Léotard
Jupé étaient globalement favorable à ce
traité du coup deux stratégies étaient
possibles la première consistait à
conduire le débat le plus vite possible
pour pouvoir évacuer rapidement ce sujet
de division premier avantage si tous les
les leaders prenaient le vote favorable
le succès du oui serait la victoire de
l'Europe et non celle de miteran
deuxième avantage personne ne pouvait
suspecter Chirac de complaisance à
l'égard du chef de l'État il aurait été
impossible d'imaginer une manœuvre de
politique intérieure le traité ratifié
l'opposition aurait pu repartir d'un
même pas à l'assaut des législatives
c'est la stratégie de banalisation
adoptée par l'UDF la deuxième stratégie
celle de la dramatisation consistait à
mener la guerria parlementaire contre le
gouvernement mais alors le débat traînit
en longueur la division de l'opposition
était de plus en plus visible la
question européenne et l'affrontement
gauche-droite étant mélangé il devenait
impossible de dire oui à l'Europe sans
que cela soit interprété comme un oui
amiterran c'est la stratégie qu'a
finalement choisi le RPR sans doute
Chirac a-til estimé qu'il était plus
bénéfique pour lui et pour le RPR de
privilégier l'affrontement
franco-français plutôt que le consensus
européen mais cela ne pouvait que
l'éloigner de ceux pour qui l'Europe est
une absolue priorité merci Albert avec
nous en direct je vous disais de
Strasbourg Simone veille et puis sur ce
plateau à côté de vous Alain Jupé
secrétaire général du RPR première
question à Simone veille j'espère que
vous m'entendez bonsoir madame bonsoir
Jacques Chirac tout à l'heure devant ses
amis du RPR a dénoncé les initiatives
prises par certains responsablebles de
l'UDF qui sont de nature a-t-il dit à
réhabiliter le gouvernement socialiste
et François mitteron est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'effectivement la présence
d'un sememble de dirigeants à commencé
par celle de Valérie cardestin à côté de
responsable socialiste et de nature à
troublé profondément vos électeurs mais
je ne pense pas parce que ce dont nous
allons parler ceux qui seront appelés à
faire ce genre de réunion c'est
uniquement l'organisation de l'Europe ça
n'est pas du tout il ne s'agit pas des
choix que nous ferons pour les
politiques amener en Europe c'est comme
nous choisirons une Constitution pour
l'Europe au fond on peut très bien
concevoir que sur le choix d'une
constitution tout le monde tout le monde
soit d'accord c'est ce qui s'est passé à
plusieurs reprises par le passé en
France et que on lutte ensemble pour
faire admettre ce cadre et qu'il y ait
même discussion autour de ce cadre pour
faire bien comprendre
que à l'intérieur il peut y avoir des
politiques qui sont des politiques tout
à fait différentes et je je j'imagine je
pense moi je suis amené par exemple à
faire une réunion vendredi prochain avec
Monsieur Fabius et je pense que l'un
comme l'autre nous défendrons pour
l'Europe des politiques qui peuvent être
différentes sur bien des sujets qu'il
s'agisse de la politique sociale ou
qu'il s'agisse de la politique monétaire
ou économique nous n'avons pas pas
certainement les mêmes positions sur les
politiques que l'Europe peut faire et
d'ailleurs dans actuell en Europe il y a
des gouvernements de tendances très très
différentes mais dans le même cadre
institutionnel or aujourd'hui ce qui
nous apparaît un certain nombre c'est de
faire comprendre qu'il est important
d'adopter ce cadre
institutionneletrouvons dans un instant
je voudrais poser une question àin Jupé
je voudrais vous demander
pourquoi pourquoi si tard alors que ces
meetings sont prévus depuis quelques
jours maintenant est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas l'effet dévastateur de
cette dramatisation subite sur l'opinion
pourquoi si tard ça commence aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas l'impression d'être en
retard par rapport à l'événement faire
un communiqué hier soir à la veille de
hier soir à la veille de cette réunion
c'était je crois le bon moment savez moi
je suis en toute chose partisan autant
que faire ce peu de la clarté et je ne
pense pas que que le distingo un peu
subtil si elle me le permet que Madame
veille vient d'introduire soit de nature
à favorisé la clarté nous n'avons pas la
même conception de l'Europe que les
socialistes et c'est tellement vrai
qu'il y a à peine 10 jours à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons essayé et nous
avons presque réussi de censurer la
politique agricole européenne du
gouvernement alors à quoi riment ces
meetings commun sinon prendre le risque
de troubler les électrices et les
électeurs vous savez moi je suis pour
l'Europe je suis prêt à ratifier Marich
mais en aucune manière à donner un coup
de main à Monsieur mitteran parce que je
pense que plutôt les socialistes
quitteront le pouvoir mieux ça vaudra
pour mon pays alors vous savez bien tous
les sondages l'indiquent depuis des
années les Français sont très tristes de
la la bipolarisation le fait que la
France soit éternellement coupée en deux
là on avait l'occasion de de voir la fin
de ces clivages partisans et puis on a
l'impression que chacun revient la case
départ est-ce que là aussi vous pensez
que les électeurs vont vont comprendre
ces cris passions vous dites que les
Français sont très tristes je crois que
ce sont les commentateurs qui sont très
tristes de la bipolarisation oui mais
les Français votent les Français votent
ils ont voté aux élections régionales
ils ont voté aux élections contonal et
moi je ne connais pas de démocratie qui
fonctionne dans laquelle il n'y a pas
une majorité une opposition c'est même
une des règles fondamentales de la
démocratie lorsqu'il n'y a ni majorité
ni opposition on se retrouve dans un
système à l'italienne et la grande
novation de la constitution de 58 le
grand acquis du gaulisme ça a été
précisément de permettre à un pays comme
la France d'être gouverné alors il faut
parler des questions de fond quelle est
l'Europe que nous voulons demain est-ce
que c'est une Europe socialiste ou
est-ce que c'est une Europe libérale je
suis sûr que Madame ve veut une Europe
libérale et de
ce oui mais c'est l'urope de giscar
pourquoi aller faire campagne avec
Madame Guigou pourquoi aller faire
campagne avec Monsieur bergovois
pourquoi aller faire campagne avec
Monsieur pzé comme mon va le faire ceci
défie le sens commun je n'arrive pas à
m'y reconnaître et nous avons voulu dire
clairement les choses je suis pour
l'Europe mais je ne fer z pas campagne
avec des socialistes Simon veille est-ce
que vous vous avez un sentiment d'être
sur cette question plus proche des
socialistes que du moi je voudrais
revenir à une question qui me paraî tout
à fait fondamental c'est celle de la
clarté et justement ce don ce que les
Français doivent savoir lorsqu'ils vont
se prononcer pour le référendum c'est
ils ont à se prononcer non pas sur les
politiques qui seront faites une Europe
plus ou moins libérale ils auront à se
prononcer sur l'architecture sur la
construction sur les institutions de
l'Europe on sait très bien que dans la
la constitution de la 5e elle a
successivement eu des gouvernements de
droite modérée puis des gouvernements
socialistes avec la même constitution
aujourd'hui sur le référendum nous ne
choisirons pas la politique qui sera
menée dans cette Europe nous choisirons
les la constitution de l'Europe et
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que c'est en fait je
comprends assez mal aujourd'hui qu'il y
ait tant de difficultés pour le RPR à
accepter cette nouvelle Constitution
parce que parce que elle est très proche
de l'actuelle et je dirais même qu'elle
est inscrite logiquement dans l'Acte
Unique si on voulait rester au traité de
Rome ne pas aller plus loin il fallait
refuser l'Acte unique mais c'était une
étape qui était qui menait
nécessairement compte tenu de ce qui
avait été décidé en 1985 qui qui menait
nécessairement à renforcer les
institutions sauf à avoir quelque chose
de tout à fait incohérent sur le plan
constitutionnel cela dit dans ce cadre
il y a des gouvernements qui sont des
gouvernements socialistes il y a des
gouvernements qui sont des gouvernements
conservateurs comme en Angleterre demain
ça sera peut-être les travaillistes
c'est toujours le même cadre c'est
là-dessus que nous aurons à voter et non
pas du tout il faut pas faire croire aux
Français que il en dépendra tel ou telle
politique agricole telle ou telle
politique plus ou moins libérale c'est
tout à fait autre chose il s'agit d'une
constitution c'est tout et je je pense
que pour ma part il aurait beaucoup
mieux valu pour ne pas que ça devienne
justement un sujet de politique
intérieure puisque monsieur Chirac
lui-même disait qu'il souhaitait un
référendum et que à l'époque il
souhaitait ratifier maestrich à ce
moment il fallait dire et bien nous nous
sommes d'accord avec ce cadre et nous
l'adoptons nous le votons sans faire des
difficultés comme il y en a eu et
probablement que ce serait déjà comme ça
a été fait dans certains pays une étape
qui est passée d'autres au contraire par
référendum se refuse mais ilut on va pas
épuiser le débat ce soir bien sûr on a
encore des semaines et des semaines je
respecte tout à fait le point de vue le
point de vue de Madame veille mais ce
n'est pas le point de vue de tout ceux
qui soutiennent malstre j'ai même
entendu des responsables éminents de
l'UDF nous expliquer que le traité de
malstetétait l'ASS t risque contre le
socialisme ce qui prouve bien que c'est
le fond aussi qui est en cause et pas
simplement la Constitution et puis je
vrais simplement rajouter un commentaire
vous V je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
se précipite tellement dans cette
affaire parce que le traité de mastrich
à l'heure actuelle et bien il n'existe
pas il y a une nouvelle très importante
qui est tombée cet après-midi le
gouvernement britannique souhaite pour
faciliter le retour dans la maison
communautaire des Danois un protocole
additionnel qui va jusqu'à limiter les
pouvoirs de la Commission cela veut dire
en réalité que la négociation est
ouverte à nouveau et ce que nous disons
avec je crois un peu de bon sens c'est
que dans ces conditions il ne faut pas
se précipiter il faut connaître le
traité dans sa version définitive avant
de prendre une position également
définitive Simone veille juste un mot
sur cette observation mais vraiment je
demanderis d'être bref parce que comme
bien entendu nous n'épisons pas le débat
ce so é j'entends de la bouche de de de
d'éminant membres du RPR depuis un
certain temps qu'il faut pas se
précipiter qu'on est les premiers or les
Anglais en définitive ont voté bien
avant nous enc pas terminé la rication
terminé mais enfin c'est passé à la
chambre c'est passé à la Chambre des
communes très largement avec un large
soutien alors qu'on a toujours dit nous
avons toujours considéré que les Anglais
étaient de mauvais européens on les a
toujours brocardés sur ce thème et puis
en définitive c'est en France où je ne
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est que
ceux qui nous disent qu'en définitive
ils ont ils sont d'accord nous disent en
même temps maintenant qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord alors je crois que ce puisqu'on
parle de transparence et de clarté que
l'on sache qui est pour puisque tout de
même ceux qui ont ont été amenés a
examiné le texte à l'Assemblée nationale
l'ont regardé ils doivent bien savoir
maintenant s'ils sont pour ou s'ils sont
contre et que c'est comme ça que les
Français peut-être comprendront un petit
peu de quoi il s'agit et quelles sont
les positions des uns et des autres sans
me répéter je voudrais quand même faire
observer que nous ne connaissons pas la
version définitive du texte et que la
révision mais non madame vous savez très
bien que la renégociation est ouverte et
nous allons voir ce qui se passe à
Lisbonne ou ce qui se passe après et par
ailleurs le processus de révision
constitutionnelle est encore au Sénat
nous n'avons pas abouti nous savons pas
ex exactement quelles sont les garanties
définitives qui seront données moi j'ai
clairement annoncé la couleur je suis
favorable à l'Europe et je suis prêt à
ratifier maestrich sous certaines
conditions mais je le répète encore une
fois pas en allant sur les estrades avec
des responsables politiques dont je ne
partage pas globalement la philosophie
politique ni même la philosophie
européenne merci Madame veille dernière
question Alain Jupé est-ce que vous vous
souvenez des termes de la petite phrase
qui vous Avaz valu le Prix d'excellence
du club de l'humour politique en 88 il y
a ça 4 ans je vais vous faire une
confidence je l'ai oublié alors je vais
vous la rappeler parce qu'elle est
parfaitement d'actualité vous aviez
déclaré François mitteran est le
spécialiste du piège à consensus voilà
alors le club de l'humour politique
précisément a décerné ses trophées pour
cette année prix d'excellence pour 92 à
COFI Gan Mian parlant ainsi de son
collègue du gouvernement Louis Le pinse
nous sommes tous deux Bretons avait-il
dit mais lui est d'avant la Maré noire
et moi d'après premier prix à Christine
Boutin député UDF des Yvelines lors d'un
débat extrêmement sérieux sur la
bioéthique il ne faudrait pas que celui
qui vient de donner son sperme s'en lave
les mains fin de citation retour aux
choses sérieuses avec de nouvelles
manifestations de protestation des
agriculteurs contre la réforme de la PAC
la politique agricole commune c'est à
Toulouse et à versaill que ces
manifestations ont été les plus
spectaculaires commentaire
ellisabethley à Toulouse toutes les
rquades bloquées ce matin par les
agriculteurs du CDJA et de la
Coordination Rurale de HauteGaronne il
protestent contre la réforme de la
Politique Agricole Commune et veulent
rencontrer leurs
députés technocr c'est personne qui
des Bonom il onis qu' sont pas
intelligents mais ils ne savent pas ce
qui se passe sur le terrain dans chaque
coin de
France à versaill une cinquantaine de
tracteurs devant le château et des
milliers de manifestants venus du nord
et du bassin parisien à l'appel des
organisations syndicales qui veulent
prouver à leur troupes qu'elles ne
baissent pas les bras même si elles ont
pris acte de la politique agricole
commune il leur faut canaliser les
revendication face à la Coordination
Rurale plus radicale qui veut faire
bouger les campagnes
en youoslavie poursuite des
bombardements de Sarajevo cette nuit le
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU a approuvé
le principe de l'envoi de casque bleu
chargé de prendre le contrôle de
l'aéroport de cette ville afin d'assurer
l'acheminement à peu près normal de
l'aide humanitaire dans la capitale de
Bosnie la France a d'ailleurs proposé de
fournir une grande partie de ce millier
d'hommes qui devrait se déployer très
prochainement sur place en tout cas
l'embargo décrété par les Nations Unies
il y a quelques jours commence à faire
sentir ses effets en Serbie où l'essence
est rationné depuis ce matin
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux Gill
Rabine Alain
duas il découvre que pendant leur
absence une semaine de vacances en
Hongrie le prix de l'essence a doublé il
découvre en même temps que cette essence
est rationnée distribué au comptegoutte
chaque jour et pour un seul
trajet c'est pour l'instant le seul
effet spectaculaire de l'embargo voté
par les Nations unies contre la Serbie
la crise économique et presque un an de
guerre ont déjà pratiquement ruiné le
pays
l'embargo ça va nous
achever le peuple va souffrir encore
plus et le peuple ser lui n'est pas
coupable
85% d'inflation le mois dernier en
serv en plus çarê pas la
guerrearg nun je entre les
puissants des Serbes le boulanger de
Belgrade son apprenti la voit grandir
jour après
jour seul le sucre l'huile et la lessive
manque mais personne n'achète car les
gens n'ont plus d'argent et depuis
longtemps c'est injuste mais on
résistera on gardera le moral regardez
autour de
vous les Français nous ont trahi ça je
comprends pas les Français nous tournent
le dos ils se couchent devant les
Allemands et les Américains on n jamais
vu ça dans l'histoire
vous vous trompez de victime moi il
voulait m'égorger en Croatie j'ai
échappé au fascistes c'est notre pays on
en a pas
d'autre qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
nous attaquer nous bombarder les
Allemands ils ont perdu deux guerres
aujourd'hui ils rêvent de revanche avec
leur marque ils ont acheté l'Europe et
Monsieur Bush lui il a acheté les
nations
uniesent les Allemands je pourrais
venger ma
famille 23 personnes tuées pour les
vivant 42 par eux et les ouachis
Croates je suis le seul rescapé et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui je dois de nouveau vivre
ça les Serbes en volent au monde entier
et d'abord à la France Com en témoi ce
monument crépé de noir ils ne
parviennent plus à surmonter ni leur
passion ni leur haine ni leur rancune ni
leur regret peut-être parce qu'ils
sentent confusément qu'ils n'ont pas su
défendre la cause serbe et qu'avec
l'embargo quoi qu'il arrive désormais
ils ont déjàd de la guerre CNN a
désormais un concurrent européen
Euronews la chaîne européenne
d'information continue par satellite et
né officiellement ce matin à Lyon en
présence des dirigeants de 11 sociétés
publiques de Radio Télévision don Hervet
bourg pour Antenne 2 et FR3 Euronews
diffusera à partir de janvier 93 en CIN
langues l'anglais l'allemand esppagnol
l'italien et bien sûr le français dès 93
donc ces images pourront être reçu dans
23 millions de foyers
européens
près d'Amboise un agriculteur excédé par
le passage d'adolescents dans ses
cultures a tiré avec un fusil de chasse
sur un groupe de 11 jeunes en blessant 5
plus ou moins grièvement reportage Anne
mourg et Christian lerou sur les raisons
de ce drame quartier de la verrerie une
cité sous haute surveillance une cité au
milieu des champs population cosmopolite
immeuble refait à neuf de gros efforts
de réhabilitation peu de chômage
jusqu'ici peu de délinquence pourtant
les jeunes ont le sentiment d'être
montrés du doigt par le reste de la vie
c'est un quartier d'étranger alors dès
qu'il y a un truc qui va pas c'est les
étrangers c'est la vere tout de suite
c'est en fait même si c'est pas laave on
est tout de suite
accusé pour se rendre en ville les
jeunes passent par ce chemin privé un
raccourci c'est là que cinq d'entre eux
ont été blessés par des agriculteurs
hier depuis longtemps les rivrins se
plaignent culture saccagée
chapardage nous on n pas beaucoup de
bêtes forcément nous on a pris une belle
lacun qui all avoir des petines et puis
quelques jours après bah c'est une boule
et puis il y a un fermier ci plus loin
une poule ça traîne tout le temps il
traîne il traîne alors faut bien qu'il
fasse quelque chose hein on n pas
tranquille ici on est tous des vieux
ici à notre mère il faut peut-être
demander quelque chose qu' nous fasse
quelque chose qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que l'on fasse on a pas de on a quatre
policiers municipaux on peut pas les
envoyer toute la
journée je dirais par là alors que il y
a d'autres problème dans le plein centre
d'Amboise elle a l'impression comme ses
voisins que les voleurs de pou peuent
ici commettre leur larsin en toute
impunité retour tout de suite à
l'événement de la soirée le meeting
commun de célesta je vous propose tout
de suite de rejoindre sur place Rachid
Arab Rachid oui BR vous m'entendez tout
cela se passe en direct madame Guigou
est en train de parler actuellement et
Valérie g cardestin se trouve je crois
derrière le rideau il attend tout
simplement je crois par politesse que le
ministre a fini son intervention ils
vont donc se rencontrer dans quelques
instants je vous propose Bruno d'essayer
de combler ces quelques secondes en vous
disant un petit peu l'ambi qui règne ici
vous m'entendez oui oui donc une
ambiance tout à fait calme une ambiance
de de studieuse dans un endroit où
habituellement se déroule plutôt des
rencontres sportives il s'agit ici d'un
d'un gymnase il y a eu tout juste
quelques impatiences au début quand les
organisateurs ont annoncé qu'il fallait
attendre l'arrivée de valerri GIS
cardestin qui se trouve toujours
derrière son rideau et qui devrait venir
s'installer dans quelques secondes
logiquement non pas face à Madame Guigou
mais à ses côtés il ne sera séparé de la
ministre des affaires européennes que
par Jean-François PC qui est
l'organisateur de cette soirée de ce
débat qui sagé à Paris et qui i
applaudiss là c'est madameou est
applaudi actuellement et je crois que
nous allons pouvoir assister à l'arrivée
de Valérie giscardesttin en direct
l'événement comme vous le disiez cet
événement qui fait t jazer à
Paris
voilà vous y assistez en direct mon cher
Bruno j'espère que vous êtes content
tout à fait demandez à votre caméraman
de de déplacer un
nous allons essayer je vais peut-être
moi me déplacer pour que vous puissiez
voir le président arriver et répondre à
cette fameuse question va-t-il serrer la
main à Madame Guigou nous allons bientôt
avoir cette cette
réponse tout cela se fait un petit peu
dans la précipitation les organisateurs
il faut le dire Bruno ont été dépassés
par l'importance médiatique de la
couverture de cette de cette réunion
alors pour l'instant un petit peu de
suspense madame Guigou a enlevé son
micro comm comme si elle avait terminé
son intervention mais malgré tout il
semble que le ministre des affaires
européennes va rester dans la salle
pendant que monsieur giscardestin
viendra ici je je le répète Bruno il ne
s'agit pas d'un dialogue entre eux il
s'agit d'un débat organisé ici à celesta
qui est animé par plusieurs journalistes
un débat qui est censé donner un lieu à
un certain nombre d'échanges de vues et
non pas à des à des discours je dirais
officiels donc il s'agit effectivement
au européens de gauche comme de droite
d'essayer de dire pourquoi ils sonent
ensemble ici et la salle est au moins
aussi impatiente que vous Bruno et je ne
sais pas si nous allons pouvoir voir
alors je faire un petit peu de radio
dans ce
cas-là on voit beaucoup de photographe
mais peut-être le président est caché
derrière l'ancien
président l'ancien président de la
République Valéri V cardestin se trouve
derrière moi et surtout derrière les
photographe qui en sont en ce moment en
train d'officialiser d'immortaliser
cette image qui a donc ant fait jazer à
Paris j'espère que dans quelques
secondes mes chers confrères qui
cherchent à faire les unes de tous les
quotidiens demain euh nous laisserons
nous aussi avoir la chance de savoir si
c'est bien monsieur Valéri juscardestin
qui est arrivé moi je le vois par
ailleurs sur un autre écan de contrôle
je peux vous dire ça sera un vrai
événement là he ça serait un vrai
événement mais je crois que je peux vous
confirmer d'ors et déjà qu'il s'agit
bien de Valérie jardestin qui est ici il
faut le rappeler en tant que président
du Mouvement européen international et
non pas en tant que responsable
politique français je crois que dans
quelques instants voilà nous allons
pouvoir enfin pouvoir vous donner
l'image que vous attendiez mon cher
Bruno et vous rendre l'antenne ensuite
voilà vous allez découvrir c'est lui
Valérie Giscard desestin installé un peu
plus de 2 m de d'Élisabeth Guigou voilà
je crois que vous avez eu l'essentiel
mon cher Bruno le débat ici va commencer
un débat tout à fait feutré voilà madame
Guigou qui a été pas mal applaudi
également tout à l'heure
je peux simplement vous signaler que la
prochaine rencontre de ce genre aura
lieu samedi à 9h et à l'affiche pierre
bergois et François Léotard
merci bien sûr nous entendrons les
principaux extraits de de l'intervention
de l'ancien président de la République
dans le dernier journal à 23h45 dernier
journal présenté par Daniel Duigou les
Bleus partent demain à la conquête de
l'Europe l'équipe de France inaugurera
en effet l'Euro 92 demain soir en direct
sur Antenne 2 je vous le rappelle en
affrontant l'équipe ha les Suédois le
sélectionneur Michel Platini a annoncé
ce matin la composition du 11 tricolore
peu de surprise Manuel Amoros a été
titularisé en défense et Pascal vaerua
participera bien sûr à la ligne
d'attaque au côté bien évidemment de
Jean-Pierre Papin tout va bien pour
notre cher numéro 9 les chevilles la
tête tout tout tout comme va nous
confirmer l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux
en Suède Olivier Reay
il faut arrêter de de me parler de cette
cheville je crois qu'elle m'a fait assez
de tort comme ça maintenant c'est fini
et PU tout va bien voilà mais si il faut
bien en parler de cette cheville son
état a inquiété tous les supporters des
Bleus le rôle de JPP est des plus
importants et l'équipe de France a
besoin d'un Papin en pleine possession
de ses moyens pour bien débuter dans cet
eur92 c'est pourquoi les médecins se
sont relayés pour soigner cette cheville
le diagnostic est plutôt
rassurant Jean-Pierre qui avait son
problème de de cheville de cartilage de
cheville les choses évoluent aussi de
façon satisfaisante je pense que
maintenant il doit être complètement
rassuré par rapport à l'état de son état
de santé à l'entraînement Papin s'est
souvent préparé à l'écart du groupe en
solitaire il s'est ménagé évitant les
contacts les chocs ce match d'ouverture
contre la Suède peut en effet se révéler
capital pour la suite de la compétition
il faut prendre de points parce qu'après
on peut gérer on peut éventuellement en
gagnant un match sur qualifier donc pour
nousement le plus important il ne lui
reste plus que demain à marquer un but
comme l'autre jour contre les Pays-Bas
un but à la JPP pour le bonheur de
l'équipe de
France ben demain en direct 20h sur
Antenne 2 dans quelques minutes un été
glacé un téléfilm signé Bernard girudeau
sur un sujet difficile l'euthanasie
thème du débat animé par Claude seron
ensuite ce soir dans Raon de plus comme
tous les mardis dernier journal vers
23h45 en compagnie de Daniel Duigou bon
anniversaire à Barbara dans un instant
donc la météo avec Laurent Cabrol
n'oubliez pas donc demain rendez-vous
exceptionnellement à 19h30 pour le
journal en raison donc de la diffusion à
20h précise du premier match de l'équipe
de France en championnat d'Europe des
nations avec une page spéciale animée
par Henry sagier en direct de Suède
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
merci à
[Musique]
demain
[Applaudissements]
piste rapide cet après-midi à Chantilly
où se disputait le tiercé ils sont 18 au
départ des 2000 m de la piste du Jockey
Club à 300 m du but Tina kazak marron et
bleu vient de prendre la tête poursuivi
par wat giift en rose jaune et rouge
incognita grena couture jaune se
rapproche vite en pleine piste à 100 m
du disque Tina a course gagné devant
incognita wat giift est attaqué par Lady
prospect casak rose et rickya en rouge
et
gris monté à la perfection par
Jean-Michel breux le 10 Tina remporte
enfin sa course le 17 incognita finit le
plus fort devant le 11 wat gift qui
résiste de justesse à l'attaque du 12
Lady prospect Gérard dubrck amène le 15
rickya à la 5e
[Applaudissements]
place rapport moyen seulement pour des
combinaisons né fa trouvé par 1 parur le
quint plus dans l'ORD rapporte
30 fr pour 10
[Musique]
Fran fil poteau poursuivi par les TR
représentants de l'écurie Chalou la to
blan et bleu d'asmen envolé finalement
River majest est deè devant
Robertino
bourmio est en tête depuis le début
asketo est encore dernier acteur
français kazak noir et jaune est très
gêné asketo trouve le passage clou sur
place ses adversaires et le favori star
of Ken est deè
devantink succès du rootield Pinky rose
monté par asusen dans la première course
de forget me monté par er Saint-Martin
dans la 5è de head quarteuse confi à
dans la
6e conserve la tête du championnat de
France des Jocky de points devant
Norbert Jean-Pierre asmusen reste 3e
foufoulou a tenté envain de se
débarrasser de son apprenti
inexpérimenté mais Patrick parzis a déjà
une bonne
assiette les courses plates sont à éri
demain images et commentaires dans le
journal des courses à l'heure
[Musique]
habituelle l'Eurofoot 92 en direct sur
Antenne 2 fr 3 suède-fance un match
décisif pour le commando de Platini qui
rêve de remporter à nouveau le plus
prestigieux trophée européen Pays-Bas
Écosse Gul van ben Richard les tenants
du titre face à une redoutable équipe
écossaise avec
schneeder et Eurocard
Mastercard suède-fance mercredi 10 juin
à 20h15 sur Antenne 2 Pays-Bas Écosse
vendredi 12 juin à 17h15 sur Antenne 2
Antenne 2 FR3 le plus grand terrain de
sport
[Musique]
Fiat présente les estivals décoration
exclusive vitres teinté toit ouvrant
radio cassette stéréo
pandap les estivals de Fiat ce sont des
voitures quiur les vacances
incorporé
bonsoir à vous tous Madame Mademoiselle
Monsieur il en va en météo comme comme
en politique le temps est à l'orage à
l'orage des orages se sont propagés sur
quasiment toute la France n allons voir
sur l'image satellite exactement où il
se situer quand ce type de temps devrait
perdurer dans la journée de demain voyez
sur l'hémisphère nord il y a une grosse
zone nuageuse sur l'Atlantique elle
devrait nous concerner dans les jours à
venir mais pas dans l'immédiat dans
l'immédiat celle qui nous concerne c'est
celle-ci nous allons d'ailleurs nous
rapprocher grâce au satellite et
constatz voyez ici il y a un enroulement
nuageux c'est une in cente
dépressionnaire qui génère cette
remontée de nuages d'air chaud et humide
les orages étaient présents sur le sud
de disons le sud de la France en général
ils vont se caler demain sur les régions
de l'Est comme nous allons d'ailleurs
l'apercevoir et le voir tout de suite
sur cette carte du temps prévu pour la
journée alors voyons puisqu'il y a plus
plusieurs zones ici c'est le temps
orageux c'està-dire sur la franche
compté la région ronalpe la Côte d'Azur
la Provence les Alpes mais aussi
l'Auvergne sur le langdoc Rossillon
tramontane va la tramontane va souffler
assez forte avec de manière assez fort
avec donc des averses et puis le Botan
se situera sur la la Bretagne les Pays
Deir et la bastandie que que n'aije
point nommé si le Pays-Basque avec un
ciel souvent obscurci les frontières là
vous savez frontières franco-obge et
Franco luxembourgeoise partout ailleurs
un ciel d'alternance avec une
prédominance nuageuse ça n'est pas
simple mais il fallait faire dans le
détail pour que vous soyez informé vous
qui habitez dans toutes ces régions les
températures maintenant pour le petit
matin entre 9 et 15°gr du nord au sud au
petit matin avec un 8°gr sur limoge qui
sera la ville la plus fraîche
l'après-midi le le thermomètre aura
tendance à se tasser à disons à baisser
très nettement entre 16 et 21 22 au nord
et entre 14 et 14 alimas jusqu'à 22 au
sud 22°r vous constatez avec moi ces
poches de d'air relativement frais 16
deg sur bi 17 sur la pointe Bretagne
faut se dépêcher le CLIN d'œil de la
météo c'est un clin d'œil frisson rien à
voir avec la température là c'est un peu
la chair de poule regardons ensemble ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis lorsqu'il y
a des meetings aériens c'est fabuleux
d'abord bon on monte dans l'avion bien
sûr enfin une façon de monter y a ceux
qui montent à l'intérieur et ceux qui
montent à l'extérieur
voici alors reste
maintenant à donner le frisson à ceux
qui sont en bas regardez attention
va-til tomber le monsieur
non il y a un fil qui
[Musique]
l'approcheut dire que dans
cette état des USA les meetings ont des
allures de voltig aérienne un peu à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans les
circles et regardez cet atterrissage
extraordinaire avant de nous séparer car
nous sommes pressés par le temps bien
entendu regardez le monsieur va attirir
sur la voiture alors qu'il reste
accroché à l'avion vitesse de l'avion et
de la voiture 120 km/h on décroche le
monsieur et l'avion bye bye superbe
voilà merci de nous avoir suivi demain
matin Sophie d'avant nous jet un coup
d'œil sur l'phéméie nous fêtrons
margarette et Landri en ce mercredi 10
juin bonne soirée sur Antenne 2 au
revoir à vous
tous quel est le plus gros transfert de
l'année en matière
[Musique]
de TI panorama le journal au cœur de la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
course deité soir à Vincen l'épreuve
d'ouverture a été une proie facile pour
son favori vainé casazac bleu qui malgré
une courte hésitation au départ s'est
rapidement installé au commandement
comme vous le voyez le domine très
sûrement végétarien qui lui rendait 25 m
et Vasco de Tartifume casac blanche 4e
Vénus de folio n'a pas été très heureuse
dans l'ultime virage récente acquisition
de Daniel Wildenstein vain et son jeune
driver Nicolas Rousell ont survolé ce
prix ukrat il ne devrait pas en rester
là les trotteurs du prix écula nous ont
offert un final superbe la victoire
revenant tout à la fin alzar casak jaune
pourtant encore loin des premiers à 500
m du but et qui a tracé une ligne droite
de toute beauté pour venir dominer as de
la Cordière en rouge et alcion de
pouline casac bleu qui n'ont pu être
départagé par la photographie am mission
se classe 4e c'est un véritable cavalier
seul qui a réalisé ami best dans cette
épreuve sous la selle assez vite en tête
malgré son handicap de 25 m il n'a alors
fait qu'une bouchée de ses adversaires
l'emportant de loin face à iglond
Clarbec et à Gill castelet en cey et
atout du closé avait décliné la lutte
dans ce semi-classique pour 4 ans vite
mtre de la première place le le favori
artiste du but assure un train régulier
mais peu rapide et accélère peu après
l'entrée de la ligne d'arrivée pour
aussitôt se mettre hors de portée de ses
rivaux Arian de Bron le long de la corde
qui tentait de le suivre s'enlève à mini
droite dont profite as desespien pour se
classer second devant amichéri et glondo
et axe des
sards artist du but et Nicolas Roussel
ont confirmé leur victoire dans le
Critérium des 4 ans et ils signent ce
soir une seconde victoire pour Monsieur
[Musique]
Wildenstein
bénéficiant d'un bon engagement union de
G en a profité pour renouer avec une
victoire qu'il a fuyait depuis fort
longtemps venu en tête dans le dernier
tournant elle n'est nulement inquiété
parapaka grande animatrice de cette
épreuve et urigo hulfon n'avait pas
couru Alain siiono partenaire d'union j
tout de suite à
l'image l'autostart était au rendez-vous
du prix hurda épreuve dédoublé réservé
au Poulin de 3 ans dans la première
d'entreelle bizibi kazak grena a tenté
tout au long de la ligne droite
d'attaquer Baikal mais ce dernier s'est
montré intraitable hauteur d'un dernier
kilomètre de toute beauté blue bonnet ce
classe 3e Briot devri était non partant
Raymond David peut-être satisfait il
tient en Baikal un Poulin de
qualité Barine de la mode s'est abstenu
dans ce groupe B du prix Urda va
remporter nettement black àou un
athlétique fils de Florestan toujours
bien placé Bleuette crépon va s'assurer
facilement le premier access site
détaché de bovini de si et baron de
bogie black Atou entouré après sa
victoire de journaux des courses demain
à 20h35 pour la Réunion d'evri et en fin
de soirée pour celle de Vichy bonsoir à
[Musique]
tous pierc panorama le journal au cœur
de la
[Applaudissements]
course
bonsoir et d'abord les titres de ce
journal première journée de la visite
officielle de la reine ellisabeth à
Paris a commencé par la remontée de
l'avenue des Champs-Élysées en grande
pompe
embouteillage monstre à Toulouse à cause
de la manive des Jeunes Agriculteurs de
HauteGaronne les barrages ont été levés
après la promesse de pouvoir rencontrer
les les élus
locaux crise au sein de l'opposition à
propos de mastrich le RPR lance un
ultimatum à l'UDF en lui interdisant de
tenir meeting avec la
gauche l'événement de la soirée c'est
Valérie giscardestin au côté d'Élisabeth
Guigou ministre socialiste pour défendre
le traité de Maastrich l'ex-président a
donc passé outre l'avertissement du RPR
lors d'une réunion publique à céesta
dans le barrain sur place Olivier Lerner
elliizabeth Guigou est arrivée la
première pas vraiment décontracté
Valérie giscarlestin plus souriant sûr
de réaliser un joli coup médiatique
était aux an il n a pas de rép du berger
à la bergère Valtin a préféré ignorer
les séères attaques de
jacquesirac je vous arrête tout de suite
je suis pas venu pour parler de la
politique politicine parler du traité de
Maastricht alors si vous voulez
m'entraîner en dehors il faut sortir de
cette salle aller ailleurs et on en
parler autrement je participe à une
campagne
d'exlication sur réser
étrangement
RS on veut nous faire croire que on est
pour
l'Europe mais qu'on est contre le traité
de Maastricht alors moi je pose la
question à ceux qui disent cela est-ce
que vous croyez que vous pouvez faire
l'Europe tout seul est-ce que vous
croyez Monsieur segin que vous pouvez
être là sur votre chaise à vous agiter
et en disant moi je veux faire l'Europe
différemment si vous trouvez pas des
Européens pour la faire avec vous vous
la ferez pas
le ton du débat est resté très poli très
technique mais en fin de soirée le
président de l'UDF s'est senti obligé de
faire écouter sa différence lorsque la
campagne du référendum sera
engagée c'est-à-dire sans doute d'près
ce qu'on nous dit après l'été et bien il
est évident que chacun fera campagne
sous ses propres couleurs ils ne se sont
pas plus salués au départ qu'à l'arrivée
il ne fallait peut-être pas en faire
trop pour ne pas exciter davantage un
RPR plutôt jaloux de cet idle
9 mois donc avant les Législatives
l'opposition risque d'exploser en
morceau hier soir l'urpr avait lancé un
ultimatum au responsablebl de l'UDF pas
question de tenir des réunions communes
avec la gauche dans ces conditions le
meeting de celesta risque d'avoir des
conséquences Rachid
Arab l'événement a donc eu lieu et même
s'il n'a duré que l'espace d'une photo
cet événement ne fera vraiment pas
plaisir à Jacques Chirac voir Valérie
giscardestin à la même tribune qu'un
ministre de François mitteran cela
laissera forcément des traces au sein de
l'opposition certes le président de
l'UDF a refusé à célesta de polémiquer à
distance avec son alterg du RPR mais en
peut penser que les comptes se régleront
un jour ou l'autre et certainement
ailleurs qu'à célesta on ne peut pas
encore dire que l'irréparable ce soit
véritablement produit au sein de
l'opposition mais enfin tout de même il
en va de la politique comme de la vie de
tous les jours lorsque dans un couple
l'un des deux partenaires décide de
s'offrir des escapades de temps en temps
avec un amant ou une maîtresse c'est
selon il fait toujours cela au risque du
divorce aux yeux du RPR la rencontre
entre l'opposition et la gauche sur le
traité de Maastrich est contre nature
invité de notre journal de 20H Alain
Jupé en a expliqué les raisons nous
n'avons pas la même conception de
l'Europe que les socialistes et c'est
tellement vrai qu'il y a à peine 10
jours à l'Assemblée nationale nous avons
essayé et nous avons presque réussi de
censurer la politique agricole
européenne du gouvernement alors à quoi
riment ces meetings communs sinon
prendre le risque de troubler les
électrices et les électeurs vous savez
moi je suis pour l'Europe je suis prêt à
ratifier Maastrich mais en aucune
manière à donner un coup de main à
Monsieur mitteran parce que je pense que
plutôt les socialistes quitteront le
pouvoir mieux ça vaudra pour mon pays au
Sénat toujours pas d'accord entre le RPR
et l'UDF pour reprendre les travaux sur
la révision de la Constitution
nécessaire à la ratification de
Maastrich sur place Véronique
Saint-Olive fallait-il reprendre le
débat de la révision constitutionnelle
nécessaire à la ratification d'un tr qui
a perdu l'un de ses signataires les
socialistes et l'UDF ont répondu oui
comme un seul homme les communistes et
le RPR ont clamé non d'une seule voix
les oui étaient majoritaires les
sénateurs se sont donc retrouvés après
le dîner mais si les orateurs se
succèdent à la tribune les tractation se
poursuivent dans l'hémicycle cette nuit
une trentaine d'orateurs vont se
succéder pour dire à tour de rôle tout
le bien ou tout le mal qu'il pense du
traité de mastrich mais demain
après-midi l'amendement sur le vote des
ressortissants communautaires revient
sur le tapis c'est alors que se fera ou
non la fracture RPR d'un côté UDF de
l'autre à moins à moins que le
feuilleton de l'opposition ne
connaissent un nouveau
rebondissement de l'Europe il en a été
aussi question avec la reine ellisabeth
lors d'un dîner offert en son honneur au
Palais de l'Élysée la reine s'est
exprimée en français avec son charmant
accent la soirée s'est ensuite terminée
au Louvre par des illuminations
exceptionnelles Bernard
Lebrun gastronomie est politique au
palais présidentiel pour un dîner de
gala réunissant 200 convives en
l'honneur de la reine Élisabeth au menu
foie gras enelé au Sauterne petit carré
d'agneau fig Grotti signe glacé élsée le
tout arrosé de Château ikem et de
château la tour
1978 invité politique d'honneur et
d'ouverture ce soir Jacques chabandelmas
Raymond bar et leurs épouses coiffé de
son diadème la reine Élisabeth en robe
blanche et argentée ne semble pas trop
fatiguée de sa première journée de s
jours elle semble même ravie de se
retrouver 20 ans après sa visite à
georgees Pompidou sous les plafonds de
l'Élysée dans la salle parmi d'autres
attendant les traditionnels discours
Catherine de neuve le comte d'Orléan
Pierre Berger ainsi que Charlotte
Rampling quel que soit leurs
inclinations
elles vont du plus au moins nos
gouvernements ont lancer le combat pour
l'Europe avec le même désir de
convaincre et de réussir l'emprunte
indélbile dont la France a marqué la
communauté n'est pas toujours
confortable pour ceux dont les
institutions reposent sur des traditions
différentes la tradition
anglo-saxone est un peu à la tradition
latine en Europe ce que l'huile est au
vinaigre il faut les deux pour faire la
sauce sinon la salade est mal
assaisonnée vinaigrette donc il était
jadis question d'entend cordiale entre
l'Angleterre et la France maintenant que
tous les ingrédients sont réunis par la
reine on pourra désormais dire que la
mayonnaise à pris entre ellisabeth I et
François mitteran un couple qui s'est
immédiatement transporté au Palais du
Louvre après ce dîner en compagnie de
Daniel mitéran et du prince consort
Philippe d'dimbourg une visite nocturne
pour assister à l'ambre rasement de la
cour Napoléon et de la pyramide cour
majestueuse dont la restauration vient à
peine d'être achevée et a été
officieusement inauguré ce soir par
cette cérémonie
[Musique]
royale le maire du man Robert Jarry a
été inculpé par le juge Renault van
runbeck dans l'affaire du financement du
PS et du PC dans la Sarte coup de colère
des jeunes agriculteur de la Haute
Garonne ils ont bloqué Toulouse en
dressant une demi-douzaine de barrages
sur les principaux axes résult et bien
c'est une belle pagaille Dorothé
oliric véritable blocus aujourd'hui à
Toulouse où les agriculteurs ont dressé
des barrages sur les routes pour
protester contre la politique agricole
commune au total une centaine de voies
ont été bloquées par des tracteurs
provoquant une des plus belles pagailles
que la ville rose est connue dans
l'après-midi on apprenait que les h
députés de HauteGaronne avaient accepté
de rencontrer les jeunes agriculteurs
demain à 14h30 les principaux barrages
ont donc été levés dans la soirée
remise en liberté des deux anciens
responsables des Girondins de Bordeaux
Claude Bez et Didier kekou ils sont
inculpés d'abus de confiance de faux et
usage de faux leur incarcération a été
jugée nécessaire par le juge
d'instruction le temps d'effectuer un
certain nombre de vérification mais le
magistrat n'a pas pu interroger
l'intermédiaire yougoslave Barin
soupçonné d'avoir été la pierre
angulaire dans le transfert de certains
joueur 5 ans après l'accident de
télésiège de luardiden dans les haute
pyrénée le procès des responsables
présumés s'est ouvert ce matin au
tribunal correctionnel de Tarbe les neuf
prévenus qui comparaissent pour homicide
et blessur involontaire se sont vu
reprocher des fautes d'imprudence de non
observation du règlement ou encore
d'inattention lors de cette première
journée de débat les inculpés se sont
sans cesse renvoyés les responsabilités
l'accident avait fait 6 morts et 38
blessés graves aujourd'hui la majorité
des victimes ont été
indemnisé les combats à Sarajevo ces
quatre derniers jours n'ont jamais été
aussi violent bilan 20 morts 340 blessés
et la grande majorité de la capitale
détruite par les bombardements hier
l'armée bosniaque a mené une
contreoffensive ce qui lui a permis de
reprendre plusieurs collines occupées
jusqu'à maintenant par les seres
aujourd'hui retour au calme la
population a pu sortir des caves et des
abris les premiers observateurs de l'ONU
devraient arriver dès mercredi pour
assurer la protection de l'aéroport 1000
casques bleus sont attendus par la suite
Jérusalem a décidé de faciliter encore
plus l'entrée en Israël des travailleurs
Palestiniens de la bande de Gaza après
14 jours de fermeture à Alger c'est
toujours la tension trois policiers ont
été tués aujourd'hui par un groupe armé
non identifié passons maintenant au
sport avec le suspense de la transat en
solitaire vent de 30 neœud mer
[Musique]
forte il a choisi l'option la plus
auonord et ça lui réussit Paul Vatine le
Havret de 34 ans a donc pris la tête de
la transate anglaise à la barre de Haute
Normandie frto sur pierre 1er de Serbie
a été pointé à la 3e position devancé
par Prim gaz et Laurent Bourgnon enfin
la transate a perdu le tonant du titre
Philippe Poupon contraint à l'abandon
après la rupture de sa
dérive mauvaise journée pour le club de
football Nant la Ligue nationale a
décidé sa relégation en 2e division
motif sa situation financière
catastrophique 60 millions de francs de
déficit Nant a décidé de faire appel
l'année dernière ce sont les Girondins
de Bordeaux qui avaient dû subir cette
d'humiliation à la veille du match
d'ouverture de l'Euro 92 qui opposera la
Suède à la France les Bleus ont fini
leur entraînement pas d'effervescence
Platini a même ménagé ses joueurs à
cause de la chaleur enfin la composition
de l'équipe a été annoncée seule
surprise la sélection de vairois préféré
à Perez l'événement demain sur Antenne 2
à suivre à partir de
[Musique]
20h coup d'œil sur les marchés boursiers
à Paris marché déprimés après le long
weekend de la P de côte - 0,67 %. à Wall
Street c'est également de la baisse
véronix
og c'était une mauvaise séance à Wall
Street ce soir l'indice da Jones a perdu
plus de 1 %- 34 points à 3369 points
comme à la Bourse de Paris ce matin les
investisseurs attendent la publication
des prochains indices économiques
américains et notamment l'inflation qui
devrait être publiée jeudi ces chiffres
détermineront la future politique de la
Banque centrale américaine le dollar lui
reste ferme face à l'ensemble des
devises le billet vert côte un dutchmark
5920 et 5 francs
35,85 en France ce soir le gouvernement
vient d'autoriser péchiné à vendre
l'ensemble de ses activités dans le
nucléaire l'opération lui rapportera
près de 2 milliards de francs 2
milliards pour péchiner les bijoux de
famille resteront quand même dans le
secteur public puisque c'est la Cogema
et Framatome qui rachète pour plus de
détails vous pouvez bien sûr consulter
votre Minitel en tapant le 3615 code eo
A2 voilà ce journal est terminé prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité c'est à
6h30 avec Télématin à 13h Philippe le
fait exceptionnellement à 19h30 c'est
Bruno Mazure car à 20h nous avons
rendez-vous en direct pour l'Euro 92
avec le match France contre Suède très
bonne
nuit
[Musique]
bvenue à vous tous madame mademoiselle
monsieurs l'animation est à son comble
des perturbations traverse la France à
l'avant et bien il y a une agitation
orageuse à l'arrière une autre agitation
orageuse bref ça s'agite dans tous les
sens voici le temps pour la journée de
mercredi avec vous le constatez et bien
voyons dans le détail très orageux dans
toutes ces régionsl c'est-à-dire sur la
franche comptée la région ronalpe la
Côte d'Azur la Provence les Alpes y
compris sur le Vergne sur le langdoc et
le Rousillon des vent vent jusqu'à 7070
km parh sur le Sud-Ouest un temps pas
très folichon quand même des éclaircis
puisque nous poursuivons le Tour de
France sur la Bretagne les Pays de Loire
et la Basse Normandie quelques oné le
long des côtes Francobelge et
franco-lxembourgeoise partout ailleurs
un ciel souvent couvert avec des nuages
abondants voilà nous avons essayé de
découper la la France en tranche les
températures du petit matin entre 9 et
15°g sans commentaires ce sont
exactement les mêmes que celles que nous
vivons en ce moment et dans le courant
de l'après-midi léger fraîchissement
vous l'avez noté 19 en Île-de-France 17
dans le centre 16 sur la presquî du
côteentin 21°gr à mulouse 14°gr
seulement à limoge ou là là la baisse
baisse bien voilà pour ceux d'entre vous
qui voyagent vous constatez avec moi que
il ne fera pas beau sur le nord de
l'Europe il fera beau en revanche sur
l'Afrique du Nord entre 23 25 et 27°gr
sur rabas Alger et Tunis et 27°gr
Athènes où en ce moment il fait très
chaud les températures étant donné pour
l'ensemble des pays européens
retournons-nous vers l'efféméride dans
ce mercredi 10 juin nous fêterons Landri
et margarette tiens margarte merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi ce bulletin météo
et bonne nuit à vous tous sur ane de au
revoir
bonjour aujourd'hui le 10 juin le 10
juin 1190 Frédéric barberous empereur du
saintempire germanique se noix la
croisade est à
l'eau
[Musique]
1949 parution de 1984
de 197 de la guerre des jours triom les
territoir
sontoch